hey guys Ryan right here yeah run right
here Ryan right right right right
so we're Ryan in the rights and know
this is Dan cyber this is Jerry reasons
to Jerry and so we're gonna watch the
gameplay trailer of Batman Arkham Knight
oh please fast
it's how water brother studios makes
their money so yeah I love the cinematic
trailer I've seen the two of the ones
I've seen of Batman Arkham Knight so far
I didn't actually get around Arkham City
but I did play Arkham Asylum which was
really cool but yeah I like that man a
lot that's why I'm wearing my Superman
shirt today to piss off all you [ __ ]
out there who like to go here you're
wearing a Superman shirt that means you
don't like Batman it's lost
I got Batman Yama's on man it's
logically impossible to like two things
um of any sort of kind yeah it's one
thing or the other that's why right now
I like soup but tomorrow I'm probably
gonna want pizza so I'm gonna have to
change oh yeah so my review on my
positive review on soup goes up today
and my negative review in suit goes up
tomorrow that's what makes getting
dressed so difficult because it's like
you know you got to wear a shirt and
pants most places but you know ya been
here just [ __ ] that's something that
90s tough it's hiring you know between
like Britney and Christina like who do
you really like at the end of the day
one in the 90s you also the option of
wearing your pants backwards anyway it's
what Batman
nice yeah wait a minute
huh [ __ ] Buffy it's it's really
thickening oh yeah oh here we go
look how big that is that's why you're
gonna do that that is so cool thank you
I kick someone like kick everyone see
this is this is neat because it seems
like they've combined you they will
really brought Batman to life here this
is [ __ ] Gotham City its enormous and
look there's no low time I mean oh dear
this is awesome they really Rock Gotham
the life
whoa
there's the cops moving on most video
games because like cops are in the
mirror after take it or leave it
she's everything everything is like a
transformer that he has like what's he
doing that's what he's doing
oh whoa [ __ ] on a bus Batman with some
real firepower dude take battle it's got
nas I was gonna leave my Batmobile it
drive home it's fine normal and you can
really fly in this game huh why kick and
glide kick oh please go and kick it's
quite kick time oh I want to do tag like
'ok at the very end that's the big
reveal o bullet I just realized to
criminal yelled that I thought he'd kick
the guy when Batman haha which would be
the greatest oh I would play the hell
out of the game if I knew Daredevils
green ledger that's some amazing
first-person point of view
well there's only one Batman said Oh
said every criminal in Gotham City ever
[Music]
partner judging by the lights
what's this
[Music]
okay that is awesome that was a cool oh
my god can you imagine being there for
that moment scarecrow is really dude
that looks [ __ ] an amazing cool I
want to play that so bad I love Ali they
just brought Gotham the life and you
could really get to explore it's like
you really get to be full on Batman you
I know it's a real city every time I see
a really cool video game trailer the
first thing I imagine is the controls
are probably very complicated yeah I'm
like this looks really awesome but I bet
it takes a lot of concentration and
hitting like right three and ABX left
like I don't I don't know what systems
controls I just described you know that
moment where he's he like does the nitro
and like jumps out of a Batmobile yeah I
imagine me doing that in gaming going
straight into a building
yeah there's no way I'm gonna be
successful at that moment it's gonna
crash into the into the bag okay when he
jumps off the building I'm so first the
moment he jumps off and the camera just
falling him down I was like it's
incredible that we can like load that
much of the map like that yeah we've
come a long way as men as men I wonder
cuz I don't know how the new systems
operate I've heard tell of certain games
like they'll take 15 or so minutes to
load everything up front 15 minutes you
go make dinner you come back your game
completely loaded boom boom in your
burger I mean this is just a real small
thing really fast is that you saw him
like run into like concrete barriers and
everything and normal you know most
games now if you do that in like GTA it
stops your entire vehicle he plowed
right through it and that's badass yeah
oh yeah the Batmobile looked amazing I
want to play that game really bad man
your birthday's coming up your
birthday's tomorrow which is probably
today wait birthday gonna guilt and get
you a massage so they say and yes yes
you know what's coming next so good
happy ending from you or from both of us
you guys are gonna forcibly massage me
yeah I'm gonna be doing it from a
distance but I will be there that's all
I mean I'll think of you as moral
support thank you
okay guys if you're new to the channel
subscribe can't copy off on the Bourbon
yeah I can drive it it's my Netflix The
Joker Joker [ __ ]
yo it's time to do some shoutouts
it's that time with a video dude I want
to first say a shout-out to this person
named Jack Mirko Jenkins awesome wait a
minute he didn't even ask for a
shout-out guys ever Ryan and the ladies
you really are entertaining this shiat
out of me thanks a lot subscriber from
Uruguay Paraguay yes range I know that
is strange I don't even I've never even
heard of that place
no what is it like a theme park or
something yeah that's it a little bit
man it's like Disneyland except with
less blackout dates Wow
they said less black guys at first I
mean there aren't a ton at Disneyland at
least you don't go on the rides that I
go on then that's like there where is
this going I don't know you just said is
there a princess and a frog right
assuming that only black people want to
go on the blind no I thought you meant
characters that don't frequent the park
they don't have a lot of places here in
Tahoe I thought you're insane black
people who go to a place where everyone
I was very yeah come on kids let's all
go to this very expensive theme park but
only ride this ride anyways you uh yeah
I just wanted to say thank you for that
and I want to give a special shout out
to a doggie out there David nuit and
shout out for me or I'll run away to
your house I'll run all the way to your
house tase you like crazy gonna run all
the way here please
tase me don't shout out I want to see
this yeah yeah I'm just concerned
dude that is I could literally have you
arrested for threatening me that way
that is not funny that is really
insulting and terrifying I mean hazing
hurts but but if we get on camera
probably get lucky pues ya so many hits
man yeah we do we're gonna do this I
think they may be come here right now I
think that is where I will draw the line
for new shows there's so Ryan getting
tased and I think we're done here the
new playlist man taser reactions they're
all bad
yeah this has been fun at this channel
but I might I might sit this one out
oh no you gotta have your own taser
playlist it's gonna be great yeah I was
hoping you'd be the main person in
crossover if it's for the YouTube videos
will [ __ ] myself out the tasing we can
have somebody tase you while you're
playing a video game oh oh what the
trailer in the background while while
Ryan sits behind you and review the
movie we're reacting reacting to the
tasing while playing amnesia but also
giving a review for guardians of the
galaxy exactly that would be like the
greatest video that's like like the son
of Yoda and borad listen you must